bene a tutti i ragazzi e per me lo dire
questo nuovo video io sono li j
faccio video su youtube perché gli piace
fare video ho iniziato inizio faccio
questo video perché scarica su questo
gioco che si chiama sa comparendo
lentamente il tipico slider di eight
pages che vuol dire se le tesi lander le
otto pagine è praticamente ho visto però
non vorrà mai provato perché un gioco
sconosciuto a si fosse già muoverti che
bello colleziona tutte le otto pagine va
bene previamente questo è un gioco dove
per la madonna a posso sul mare con la
faccia zoom con gli occhi io mi immagino
personaggio che ci ha gli occhi che gli
escono dalle orbite si avvicinano al
punto in cui sto zoomando bello
praticamente mimì mi sembra più che sia
un gioco horror però non ne sono sicuro
perché ho visto che delle persone ci
giocavano è praticamente c'è questa
torcia che possiamo accendere
illumina la zona beh sembra bello come
gioca una bella grafica vabbè comunque
ragazzi lo metto la mia faccia nel video
perchè non non so non mi vergogno
volendo con trovare queste otto pagine
ma di preciso dove che bella questa
sedia che bello strabuzzare gli occhi
per guardare meglio la sedia o guardate
c'è un suo gigantesco che carino mi
piacciono questa è la cosa più allegra
che ho visto da quando ho iniziato
questo gameplay mi fa molto piacere ho
trovate una pagina ragazzi cresce la mia
trovato una delle otto pagine che sono
nascoste in questa la foresta qua
questo c'è scritto no no no non lo so
che la stessa risposta che mi danno le
ragazze quando provo a chiederle se
vogliono diventare le mie ragazze come
si prenda eccolo prezzo 1 su 8 di una
banca infame maledetta di sono ragazzi
mi chiama me lo ricordavo così stato
intonato stagione volevo dire cos'è a
quella roba lì che mi ha fatto cagare in
mano a una persona senza la faccia mia
pena
quando mi sono preso un in mezzo in
fatto che tra l'altro l'ho dovuto
seminare perché mamma mi ha mai voluto
forte ragazzi via perché non vedo più
niente nello schermo cos'è questo gioco
mamma mia che brutta cosa e dall'altro
la tizia si è messo a correre più veloce
adesso che mi sono preso lo spavento
bene dove siamo finiti che ho trovato il
cambio di scooby doo
ma non è il cambio di stupido però
trovato un'altra pagina non guardare o
ti prenderà ma chi il tipo di prima è
uno e uno stalker
ma chi non credo di aver motivo per il
quale qualcuno debba stalker armi sono
pure brutto non metto neanche la webcam
division autostima perché dovresti
seguirmi scusami madonna quanto si
brutto barba bene comunque ho sempre più
facile madri fan
bye bye bye bye di omaggio ai fornitori
colli quanti problemi a questa donna
sempre ammesso che sia una donna però a
giudicare dal modo in cui ansima
io non sono sicuro ragazzi che questo
gioco possa piacervi io spero di sì
perché cerco di portarvi un contenuto
che vi piace però non non penso
veramente di fare carriera su questo
sito ho trovato un'altra pagina dicevo
non penso di limi alone lascia lì solo
ecco dicevo e non penso che di poter
iniziare chissà quale carriera con
questo video qua però in qualche modo
spero che vi piaccia comunque perché io
cerco sempre di portare contenuti che vi
piacciono e cerco sempre di non farli
annoiare i fatti alle volte parlo senza
sapere neanche che cosa sto dicendo per
farvi credere che io abbia un discorso
ma in realtà non sto dicendo niente
follows ti segue ma non è vero non c'e
nettuno che bello questo gioco mi piace
un sacco siamo a metà ragazzi quattro
gli otto che comunque un posto più alto
di quelli che prendono adesso a scuola
perché se gioca a questi giochi di merda
come faccio ad andare
se non lo so neanche io però va peggio
chiamo cit
comunque andiamo avanti finché non
riesco a trovare tutte le pagine ragazzi
io non mi do per vinto perché per un
ragazzo di 17 anni come me molti ragazzi
al giorno d'oggi pensano a trovare
ragazzi e le fidanzate a costruirsi un
futuro
io no io sono un ragazzo che invece a
queste cose non gli interessano voglio
solo trovare le pagine in un gioco
horror anche fatto abbastanza brutto di
grafica ma non mi interessa questi sono
i miei obiettivi nella vita questa cosa
per caso vi da fastidio perché a me non
dà fastidio è il film che bello sempre
che zummo elmi aiutami 5 su 8 marchio
lacca l'ho trovato subito ragazzi la
musica sia intensificata credo di aver
raggiunto un livello di difficoltà più
elevato in questo momento infatti il
tipo si sta proiettando sul mio
diventano
in modo sempre più frequente la cosa mi
disturba potrei essere morto ma non è
detto io non cedo non cederò non cederò
a quest uomo magro senza faccia ma anche
se senza faccia comunque con più barba
della mia e poi non potete saperlo
perché non c'è una webcam però io vi
giuro che non ho neanche un pelo in
faccia e ora ho 17 anni ma credo che
anche quando ne avrò 22 non avrò pelo
sulla faccia eccolo qua un'altra pagina
questa volta non c'è scritto niente ma è
rappresentato quello salve che cosa è
successo sono morto
cliff tu continui sono morto
va bene riproviamoci ragazzi non so cosa
dirvi ci ho provato però è stato bello
sono arrivata 68 è un buon risultato
solo una prima partita che bello questa
volta ho trovate un albero gigante con
una pagina sovra always sci snow ice
sempre che guardano negli occhi
neanche io gli occhi guarda o una
videocamera installata nel cervello è
bellissima questa cosa vorrei avere
questo potere nella vita reale per
guardare i culi delle ragazze che mi
piace senza farmi scoprire perché sono
timido non ho capito se questa è una
sorta di check point quindi dove puoi
stare che non ti arriva nessuno
ecco forse non è la mia idea è stata
immediatamente presa è buttata nel cesso
con tanto di sciacquone tirato perfetto
siamo di nuovo a tre aula solo bravo e
ragazzi per non aver mai giocato a
questa cosa ma do che cos'è questa cosa
c'è anche una pagina
cos'è questa roba è ormai aspetta
elabora battuta poco divertente sembra
un mega vinto
che figata li mia nonna lasciami da solo
4 su 8 grandissimo siamo a metà di nuovo
ragazzi non lasciarmi da solo sono io
che a me devi lasciarmi da solo non a te
c'è cui io non ci sto pagando sento che
mi sento ragazzi non ho neanche visto
dove era sento solo questi rumori mica
go addosso per favore possiamo cambiare
il gioco
ho visto un altro gioco carino che
sarebbe bello iniziare su questo canale
ma non sono sicuro che possa avere
successo
si chiama è e bwin e poi poi vediamo
perché mi sembra un gioco un po violento
poi io non dico neanche le parolacce
perché sono una persona educata e non ho
intenzione di iniziare un canale dove
dove dovevi con ei video le parolacce e
una cosa che non si fa
siamo tornati a 6 su 8 ragazzi sono
carico per il finale di questo gioco
bello nuovo che appena uscito dai altre
due paginette che cosa ti costano
no no basta ragazzi basta vi giuro è
difficilissimo è un gioco molto
difficile anche se è brutto di grafica e
brutto pro è difficile ragazzi miei io
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
scusatemi lo so che non c'era la webcam
come invece altri youtuber più
conosciuti di me mettono ad esempio zona
però spero che vi sia piaciuto lo stesso
il video perché mi sono impegnato non la
metterò mai credo perché sono troppo
timido come come ragazzo se mai
dovessimo fa raggiungere in una realtà
alternativa non lo so tipo come 4
milioni di iscritti allora farò vedere
la mia faccia per adesso
meglio di no lasciamo perdere però che i
video vi sia piaciuto se vi dove è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
vorrei mettere un altro alla fine del
video con un televisore che gira ma devo
ancora scari rubarla qualcuna
su youtube io per adesso non sono non
l'auto scusatemi e ci rivediamo ad un
prossimo video non horror bella ragazzi